adam says I understand that marketers
ruin everything but his Twitter's latest
algorithm change going to damage the
user experience and the essence of
Twitter Adam congrats on getting on the
show guys let's give a huge shout out a
collective shout out in the comments and
go on Twitter and give him a shout out
adam has hasselt has asked a lot of
questions he has persevered he's taken
my advice from some other episode
recently where I just said keep asking
keep asking keep asking he didn't give
up a lot of you've given up a lot of you
have stopped using the askgaryvee
hashtag to try to get on the show with
your question because that for 20
episode you didn't get on loser
mentality winner's mentality is Adam who
is completely over indexed on asking
over and over and over to get on the
show big props to you brother they
answer your question life is very simple
whether it's for Twitter showing you ads
or Facebook which is set this up for
Twitter because they're following that
notion of discovery whether it's dating
the most attractive guy or girl you've
ever dated before but they actually
aren't that nice of a person and you
actually just don't like them that much
this is more of a guy thing from what I
can tell for my girlfriends but like
that notion that same psychology plays
out on this answer which is the world is
predicated on the value it's providing
you versus what it's doing to otherwise
meaning what without a dog if you're
listening that was not a dog ah from
what we could tell my friends it's very
simple it's the value proposition it's a
seesaw does it kill Twitter it kills
Twitter for the people that don't value
everything else that Twitter does and
find seven to 10 more tweets in their
stream not valuable enough right when
when you're a young guy and you get that
hottest girl that you've ever dated
she's so pretty you don't care about
that she's like hurting your feelings
and mean to your friends and not letting
you hang out with your friends and all
you let that all go because you value
the beauty over that and as you evolve
eventually if she's the worst you can
finally after the beauty subsides and
you've calibrated the beauty you go the
other way and that's just the way it is
about life you love your
family so much that you let them get
away with so much that's the bottom line
Facebook has enough value in keeping up
with your friends and has a lot of data
to show you the stuff that you actually
want to see and that's why we're
tolerating it and you can tell me the
kids are going off of it and they're on
snapchat Instagram and so are you and
that's fine that makes sense but
Facebook's data shows the world it's
true there were still on it at enough
scale if Twitter's unable to do that or
any other product in the world tumblr
was very valuable to high school kids it
was a different creative place they
didn't make the shift to mobile fast
enough and good enough and they lost her
value proposition when something else
came along what happens when the pretty
girl with an awesome attitude comes
along and so the answer to this question
and you can see I've used human kind of
like what we all grew up with kind of
psychology is very simple which is it's
all about the value prop right the
second this show doesn't bring you
enough value you stop watching period
end of story and that's what it's all
about and so twitter has a challenge of
making sure its product brings enough
value that the little things that maybe
don't bring you value still don't offset
the value oh crap wait subscribe I need
subscriptions because I can't push this
many right hooks in social so subscribe